what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and today is the day
that black clover finally went all out
the spade kingdom arc has been building
up to this for months and months and now
the unthinkable finally happened
lucifero himself has emerged from the
underworld in his true form on top of
that he has already demonstrated
unbelievable levels of power and asta is
scared and sweating bullets this was
massive and game-changing so we need to
talk about it if you guys enjoy our
black lower videos and you want us to
keep them coming you know what to do
just leave a quick like and comment it
only takes a second but it helps with
the youtube algorithm and if you want a
completely free way to directly support
this channel just take a second to
subscribe hit the notification bell and
select that option that says all a quick
thank you to raid shadow legends for
sponsoring this video wanna play an
awesome free game and also support this
channel at the same time just use my qr
code or links below to download raid on
mobile or pc raid always has amazing
updates but my favorite one this month
is hydra the insane new boss with
multiple heads and each head is a
complete boss fight on its own you've
got the head of blight which uses the
power of poison the head of torment
which uses true fear to terrify enemies
head of mischief which steals your buffs
the head of wrath which weakens and
provokes your entire team head of decay
makes your team's healing actually lower
its hp and finally the head of suffering
causes your champions to take some
damage whenever you attack it what a
terrifying boss and what a great new
challenge for all epic gamers out there
and now raid is also giving away a super
limited edition champion esports legend
and navi superstar simple between now
and january 28 2022 simple's limited
edition champ is available for free to
new and old players all you have to do
is log in for seven days between now and
january 28th but if you miss the date
you will miss out forever now is the
best time to start playing just click
the link in the description or scan the
qr code right here new players will get
an epic hero tyrell two hundred thousand
silver one xp boost one energy refill
and one ancient shard you will find your
rewards here in your inbox for the next
30 days only finally this video will of
course contain black clover manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned so in the previous
chapter everything was looking pretty
dijobo for our heroes with the lucifero
monster destroyed and yami and william
liberated the cliff off could no longer
remain open and so theoretically the
battle should now end i mean there might
be a few low and mid-ranked devils who
came in from the underworld earlier on
but they would be taken care of pretty
easily however we all knew that this was
not the end of the big battle and
certainly not the end of the arc if you
watched my previous video about the last
chapter i said that it was highly
unlikely that the battle would actually
end here nanai said that lucifero must
have already managed to manifest in some
way so even if the cliff off does close
the battle will still continue i mean
again we can't forget that sekei is a
part of this fight and we haven't even
seen a tiny fraction of his true power
yet tabata would never end this arc
before giving us what we all want and
need dark lord sekei unleashed this
latest chapter confirmed my suspicions
and then some so let's break it down we
begin with those massive chunks of the
lucifero monster dropping towards the
ground and it looks like they are about
to crush a bunch of spade kingdom
citizens to death thankfully yuno
appears in the nick of time and
disintegrates the massive chunks of the
monster with his spirit of euros arrows
we see that as he's firing mimosa is
standing right behind yuno so she must
be healing him from the wounds he
sustained during his big battle against
xenon asta is of course extremely proud
to see his friend and rival emerge
victorious although asta is not
surprised since he has high expectations
of juno and yuno definitely lived up to
them realistically both yuno and hasta
have been extremely impressive during
this spade kingdom battle and they both
deserve a ton of respect that said osta
is still the mvp in my opinion he took
down lilith and the ma and the lucifero
monster and he even helped out a bit
against megicula that is actually insane
when you think about it asta's progress
has been absolutely incredible and
before this arc he was nowhere near this
strong so it's just crazy then we
actually get like half a page focusing
on william and we see padre jump up and
grab him before he falls to the ground
william appears to be conscious as he
weakly says pawtry's name and that is it
that's all we get on william in this
chapter he is okay both of his fans are
happy and now we can move on to the
captain that we all really care about
captain yami as the black bulls gather
around yami with tears of joy in their
eyes yami says well done to all of them
and it is a beautiful wholesome moment
that lasts about 14 seconds before the
world is turned upside down yet again
but let's take it one step at a time we
see the various clover kingdom knights
and spade kingdom citizens breathing a
sigh of relief and they all really seem
to think that the battle is over except
for dark lord sekei of course he knows
the truth and he is powering up as we
speak you can see it in his face just as
the spade kingdom citizens are thinking
about their future and about rebuilding
the kingdom and just as they embrace
yuno as the long-lost true heir to the
spaid kingdom throne a young looking
devil suddenly appears next to some of
the spade citizens he looks like this
chill teenage emo devil and he asks the
people there why they are taking it so
easy as the people look at him in total
shock he tells them that the sooner they
get out of here the better suddenly the
atmosphere in the story shifts
completely and knocked who is near where
that emo devil has manifested realizes
that this devil must be the supreme
devil from the second level of the
cliffhoth this devil then casually tells
everyone that lucifero's manifestation
has managed to make it halfway through
from the underworld and in that moment
the remnants of all of that dark evil
magic seem to morph into an absolutely
terrifying figure this devil has long
white hair four curved horns four
bat-like wings and he is definitely
something straight out of a horror film
the devil looks up and points to the
people and then he says in a terrifying
voice that the heads of those people are
raised far too high at least i assume
that his voice is terrifying manga
obviously doesn't have sound but i mean
it's got to be with this freaking
terrifying introduction then with the
movement of literally one finger
lucifero forces everyone around him to
drop to the ground and in fact they drop
so far that they smash into the earth
beneath them with their bodies and we
are not only talking about random spayed
civilians here overpowered clover
kingdom mages like fugolian nosel real
charlotte and others have also dropped
to the ground or i guess halfway into
the ground and we see that even the
spade kingdom houses in the area have
collapsed and this is what lucifero was
able to do with his gravity magic by
moving just one
single finger oh and yeah this is him at
only half his power because he only
halfway manifested into this world that
is absolutely freaking insane like what
i didn't see marilona there specifically
but if she too was taken down so easily
by lucifero and she managed to defeat an
ancient giant demon on her own then
lucifero's power is absolutely off the
charts this has completely changed the
power scaling game in black over in the
span of just a few panels wow asta seems
as shocked as the rest of us and he
hurries back to see what happened oh and
by the way asta is no longer in his
devil union mode he is back to normal
and liba is once again in his chibi form
and resting on asta's shoulder i'm not
sure if foster deliberately stopped
using devil union to conserve his energy
or if his time is already up but it's
safe to say that if foster can't go back
into double union for another 30 minutes
then everyone is absolutely screwed as
austin liebe approached the area where
everyone had been standing lucifero
suddenly appears right next to him
lucifero says you were the bastard who
was foolish enough to interfere with my
complete manifestation asta looks at him
with pure shock in his eyes and sweat
dripping down his face and that is how
this chapter ends whoa i knew that
lucifero would not be defeated after
what happened in the last chapter and i
knew that we would get to see his true
form eventually but this is still such a
crazy twist what an absolute atmosphere
shift in only a few panels and i have to
say that lucifer's true form looks just
as i had imagined it he is an absolutely
menacing and haunting creature of
darkness that exudes terror and power it
seems that like megicula he is now able
to reveal his true form even though his
manifestation is still only partial in
his case it is now at 50 percent and
with what we've seen from him already in
terms of power i can't even imagine what
this monster would be able to do if he
was ever to fully manifest into this
world i'm not gonna lie this looks
really bad right now for everyone
involved because if austin is out of
devil union and literally everyone else
has been ko'd by one of lucifer's
fingers then our heroes do not stand a
chance unless sekei is finally done
powering up because then lucifero will
meet his match oh and i know that a
bunch of you guys think that i'm just
memeing when i say this seikei stuff and
you probably think i'm taking it too far
but no i'm 100 serious sekei is the goat
definitely let me know what you guys
think will happen next because i just
don't see how anyone will be able to
take down lucifero after what we've seen
in this chapter we of course have to
assume that asta will find a way to keep
fighting we have to assume that yami and
probably merolona will also find a way
to resist his gravity and start fighting
back as well and of course seki that
goes without saying but will any of it
matter against such a freaking monster
one potential wild card is that emo
supreme devil who seemed way less
vicious than the other supreme devils
we've met and who by the way seemed a
lot more human-like in terms of
appearance than the other devils to me
he looks more like sacre than he does
say zagred or lilith and amma the emo
devil even told the spade citizens to
try to escape to safety and that
definitely caught me by surprise was he
just messing around like he was trying
to toy with his prey or could he really
be a different kind of devil we know
that not all devils are necessarily evil
and not all of them are big fans of
lucifero so perhaps like liebe this
devil actually dislikes lucifero and
maybe he might even turn on lucifero if
the opportunity arises i mean that is
heavy speculation at this point it is a
big stretch given that we know almost
nothing about the emo devil but i would
love to hear your thoughts down in the
comments below both about the emo devil
and lucifero and what's gonna happen
next if you guys enjoyed this black lore
video and you want to see more in the
future you know what to do leave a quick
like it only takes a second but it
really helps with the youtube algorithm
and if you're new to anime pro or maybe
you watch our channel but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
make this the video that you subscribe
hit that notification bell and select
the option that says all if you don't do
that you're still going to miss a ton of
our videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopro as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you